[Music]
what we know is that to them has this
material you don't know that I mean he
just keeps repeating the lie just
because you're the Prime Minister it
doesn't mean you get to make up your own
facts someone in this building has
betrayed their country
if you are found to have withheld
information you will be charged with a
breach of the Official Secrets cousin
gum did you think - because we know they
brought you this friend
be careful this is real you can go to
jokes for having in your possession
you're a spy you work for the British
government
no I work for the British people
I do not collect information so that the
government can lie to the British people
intelligence may be being manipulated to
take this country - all stop taking Tony
plana face value
you had nothing to gain and everything
to lose this could result in a prisoner
sentence do you want to risk it all
[Applause]
everywhere every country biggest
demonstration in human history if we do
not go published we would be conceded
that no one who ever tell the people
when their government is lying
[Music]
we did
I was extraordinary the war is illegal
the public is entitled to know why my
motive was to stop a war and save lives
I have to tell the truth
you